le temps des fêtes coûte cher que ce
soit en cadeau en nourriture également
avec les repas de famille en l'argent
est une des plus grandes causes de
stress mais le début de l'année
peut-être un moment idéal pour prendre
des résolutions 1 pour nos finances
personnelles j'en parle avec nicolas
blais les professeurs au département des
sciences comptables de l'université du
québec à trois-rivières bonjour monsieur
velay bonjour alors ce une bonne idée ça
a commencé l'année sur une bonne note
financière avec une belle résolution
comme ça absolument dans la foulée de
résolution les financent pour partie
aussi importante de notre vie et je
pense qu'on doit s'en occuper à longueur
d'année parfois en fin d'année on
s'aperçoit qu'on a peut-être pour
respecter notre résolution de l'année
d'avant c'est un bon moment présentement
c'est propre et ça sort des jours de
l'an faire le point et jean reyrat le
choc des comptes de cartes de crédit oui
malheureusement il ya beaucoup personnes
qui s'endettent qui achètent beaucoup
plus qu'est ce qu'ils sont capables de
payer les quarts des crédits c'est un
bon véhicule pour régler nos achats on
peut aller chercher des points de
récompense seul il ya plein d'aspects
positifs
il faut faire très attention ne pas
excéder notre capacité de paiement parce
que effectivement comme vous l'avez
mentionné en janvier qu est ce qui
arrivera au tour du quinze du vin selon
nos nos dates de réception de relever on
recevra la belle surprise de ce qu'on a
dépensé souvent dépenses éphémère donc
on va avoir à payer sur un étalement de
temps des dépenses dont le plaisir était
consommée déjà et on parle d'un
financement qui a 20 pour ça donc faut
faire très attention
la mère chose à faire est ce que c'est
pas justement de se faire un budget dès
le début d'année parce qu'on en fait
profiter un peu de ce choc qu'on va
avoir avec ses comptes à payer
c'est toujours un moment un peu un peu
stressant edit bon mais je vais me
prendre en main et je vais faire un
budget on commence pas tout à fait donc
un budget pas besoin d'avoir des
connaissances spécifiques en finance
pour s'établir un budget on y va de
façon très simple au départ pour un
salarié
les entrées de fonds nettes faut
comprendre ce qu'on gagne pour
comprendre ce qu'on est en mesure de
dépenser et 200 gardé suffisamment pour
épargner donc d'établir le budget
familial des entrées de fonds nettes
pour le travailleur autonome ça peut
être un petit peu plus complexe mais ça
se prévoit quand même on connaît nos
clients on connaît notre notre année
dernière n'est capable de planifier du
mieux au mieux de notre
sens donc ça c'est la base qu'est ce qui
rentre dans le budget de pièces mais
maintenant qu'est-ce qui sort en partant
on a toutes nos dépenses obligatoires
pensant aux loyers à l'hypothèque
pensant aux dépenses d'électricité
d'épicerie la scolarité des enfants tout
ce qui est inhérent la scolarité par la
suite télécommunications passé à tous
qu'on est obligé de payer ce aussi sur
quoi on est déjà commis du type paiement
de voitures qui est déjà contractés donc
on établit ces dépenses là et là on voit
qu est ce qui nous reste
alors s'il n'en reste pas un sou sans
hormones à l'insuffisance de fonds et
l'on doit planifier comment on va
rationaliser nos dépenses et des
dépenses qui sont plutôt discrétionnaire
on doit couper pour arriver à dégager un
surplus ou minimalement arrivé à
équilibre il ya beaucoup de dépenses qui
sont mensuelles qui reviennent vraiment
de mois en mois à peu près le même
montant alors que d'autres dépenses vous
gardiez la scolarité bon l'entrée
d'école ces deux sont des moments de
l'année septembre coûtent très cher
entre autres noël également on peut
planifier ça dans notre budget dès le
début de l'année et se met de l'argent
de côté pour ces moments absolument on
est capable d'identifier nos dépenses de
façon estimative quand même assez
précise de façon mensuelle
comme vous l'avez dit on sait que
décembre kutscher septembre également
juillet les vacances d'été enfin mais on
est capable d'aller se mettre des
petites provisions ou ces moyens
coûteront plus cher et pour le reste de
l'iss et nos dépenses sur l'année et
d'essayer au mieux de suivre cette
planification là pour arriver à
idéalement dégagé un léger surplus pour
se créer une sécurité financière dont
certains vont penser selon l'avons passé
à l'avenir vont vouloir investir est ce
que tu as à bord au moment d'investir en
début d'année je suis obligé de vous
dire que c'est toujours le bon temps
d'investir comme cpe je vous dis faut
vraiment les institutions financières
vont nous mettre souvent en tête que
j'envie février c'est la période
derrière
moi je crois pas ça dans le fond
l'époque ça se constitue à tous les
jours de façon plus concrète on va
parler à chaque pays our mensuellement
de constituer une réserve et on va
placer selon les turbulences du marché
ça monte ça descend on continue de
placer tout le temps et ça devient un
automatisme donc on regarde dans le
rétroviseur quelques temps après et obs
on s'aperçoit qu'on a accumulé une somme
qui au départ est petit à petit qui
devient substantielle et avec le jeu des
intérêts composés qui se constitue qui
se constitue donc y rendre une bonne
idée si on veut prévoir les dépenses à
venir pour l'éthique de sortir son
compte principal pour d'abord qu'on voit
que c'est pas dans nos opérations
quotidiennes puis d'avoir l'occasion
d'aller voir quel montant elle vous fait
plaisir aux comptables sa danse créé une
provision objectivement et on peut
épargner pour deux pour différents aux
différents types de projets comme la
retraite qui du très long terme mais
également comme vous le dites du court
terme on sait qu'on va partir en
vacances en juillet on a besoin de 4000
$ 3 de dollars ce salon les plans de la
famille mais pourquoi ne pas constituer
tout de suite 1 250 dollars par pays de
sorte à arriver à temps pour les
vacances et ne pas avoir le souci de
mettre sur la carte de crédit et vivre
peut-être l'année prochaine un mois de
janvier beaucoup plus léger oui avec
beaucoup moins de stress alors à une
opération d'une résolution à prendre
cette année pour bien des gens oui merci
beaucoup monsieur blé j'avais une petite
lecture et a suggéré nos auditeurs jeune
mes collègues professeurs bachand de
l'iut a requis écrit un bel ouvrage qui
s'adresse à monsieur madame tout le
monde qui est un langage accessible qui
s'appelle les par un choix pour soi
c'est totalement gratuit c'est
disponible sur le site fiscalité cutter
point c'est accessible pour tous
directement en ligne et dans un langage
compréhensible pour inciter à l'épargné
au budget donc une lecture de début
d'année
oui une belle sélection